>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> NICHOLAS BROWN: Good
evening ladies and gentlemen.
Welcome, my name is Nicholas
Brown, I'm a music specialist here
at the Library of congress.
So, great to see so
many of you today.
Hope it didn't take too
long given the weather
and transportation mayhem that
was had today in Washington, DC.
We're so thrilled that we have all
of the artists here tonight as well
as the composer of the
piece being premiered,
Kati Agocs, who is at the far end.
And she made it from
Boston despite all
of the transportation
nonsense today,
so we really appreciate
her putting up with all
of that to join us this evening.
And I'll just introduce the rest
of the quartet members to you.
This of course is the
Cecilia Strong Quartet.
They're based in Toronto.
And we have Min-Jeong
Koh, first violinist.
Sara Nematallah, also violin.
Caitlin Boyle on viola.
And Rachel Desoer on Cello.
Awesome. Yeah, welcome.
[ Applause ]
So, we're just going to have
an informal chat to talk
about their experience with the
Stradivari instruments and also
with the repertoire and then also
bringing Kati's piece to life
as they've given the
world premiere already
and some other performances of it.
Just some context about
this evening.
This is our annual
Stradivari concert,
also known as the Stradivari
Anniversary Concert.
And we invite a string quartet and
sometimes some other guest artists
to perform on the library's historic
string instrument collection.
Specifically, the violins, and
viola, and cello that were donated
by Gertrude Clarke
Whittall beginning in 1935.
She actually built this room.
We're in the Whittall
Pavilion here at the library.
And she was a very wonderful
philanthropist who liked to compete
with Mrs. Coolidge who of
course build the hall next door.
There's a difference
of about 10 years
between Mrs. Coolidge
giving her initial gift
and then Mrs. Whittall's
gift of the instrument.
Tonight's events mark
the 80th Anniversary
of the first Stradivari
Anniversary Concert.
So, this is a lot of redundant
use of the word anniversary.
I'm sorry and we're very pleased
to be featuring the
Cecilia Quartet tonight.
Beyond that, we're also honoring
the upcoming 150th anniversary
of the confederacy of Canada.
And they're mostly
Canadian, if not all Canadian
and definitely all based in Canada.
And Kati, is also Canadian,
which is really great
and she was born in Ontario.
So, we are all Canada
all night today
which is really great [laughter].
They're so charming, aren't they?
[ Applause ]
So, I'll start off with the
quartet, because they've been here
since Thursday evening, getting
to know some of our dear friends
that usually live in
those cases over there.
We have several of the
instruments being used tonight
of course, there are four.
The Betts Violin from 1704, the
Castlebarco Violin from 1699,
the viola from 1727,
known as the Cassavetti
and then the Castlebarco
Cello from 1699.
What has the experience been
like meeting these instruments
and also coming to terms with them
or conquering them
in the last 48 hours.
And that's open for any one or all.
>> RACHEL DESOER: Well,
it's been an adventure.
And I think this evening
will be even more of one.
I'm trying to think, there's
just actually so many variables
and things that happen
when you first encounter a
different instrument.
And I sort of feel like I've met
a person who would be like one
of my greatest friends,
like just immediately love,
but have no idea how
to talk to them yet,
like they're from a different
country or something.
So, yeah, I guess that's
where I sort of started.
>> MIN-JEONG KOH: Because I
feel like I'm having an affair.
[ Laughter ]
And I'm already dreading
tomorrow when I have to say bye,
I mean the Betts strat, it's a
remarkable instrument and it's just
so many wonderful things about it.
And I think you know when you're
freshly in love with someone,
just everything seems so
perfect and just so, it just,
you know it fits perfectly.
So, I'm in this you know la-la
land where you know I think we're
like the greatest couple
ever created by man
and my pour violin
is actually here too.
And it looks kind of you know dirty,
and you know it looks a little,
feels a little bit shafted I think.
>> SARAH NEMATALLAH: Yeah
it's been a great honor
to play on the instruments.
I feel quite humbled
by the experience.
We're really honored to be invited.
And I think what's been most amazing
for me is the way a different
instrument can actually teach you
things about yourself
that you couldn't get
from your regular instrument.
So, I've just been
noticing different movements
that are possible, you know
on instruments in general.
Different sounds that are possible.
Like you learn so much, even from
just a few days on the instrument.
So, it's a pity that we
obviously can't have more time,
as I'm sure everybody feels
who comes to play on these,
but even the short time is
really, really enlightening.
>> CAITLIN BOYLE: Yeah I was going
to say something similar to Sarah.
Well, I've never actually played
on an instrument this old before.
A lot of violas are
more contemporary.
And I feel like I've
learned a lot from it.
Like the response of the
instrument is just, it's incredible.
It's so fast and it will
just, like we were talking
about an analogy also of like
driving a very expensive car.
So, like Rachel said, it's a
little bit scary and dangerous
because it jumps at like the
slightest thing that you do.
And the sound is just incredible.
I find it so smooth and full.
So, it's been such a great pleasure.
>> NICHOLAS BROW: Could
each of you share maybe one
of the biggest surprises about
your specific instrument.
And it doesn't have to be cheerful.
>> CAITLIN BOYLE: Okay.
Well I was like, for some
reason I had it in my mind
that the Strad here was huge.
Was going to be this
massive instrument.
So, I was you know
practicing like this before.
No, I'm just kidding.
But it's actually smaller
than my own viola.
So, that was a bit of a relief for
me since I don't have to struggle
at all physically to play.
>> RACHEL DESOER: I think the first
day I looked at the instrument,
there's a spot on the back that
looks at either a knot of wood,
or perhaps we were discussing
it might be a fossilized worm.
And so, that just made the
age really hit me in the face,
but also very odd to like lightly
put your hand over wood that felt
like a little soft and fragile.
So, it's a good thing
it lives in that case.
>> MIN-JEONG KOH: Oh, there
are just too many I can't pick.
Well, I think when you,
as soon as you put the bow
on I think it feels buttery,
but in high on the E string,
which of course is the best string,
I think it really requires
like no effort.
And somehow it has this
amazing ability to project
and create this unbelievable
sound, but without much effort.
It's as if it has like
a little tiny built
in mic underneath the
bridge or something.
It's amazing.
>> SARAH NEMATALLAH: Yeah
I had a similar experience.
I guess I was surprised that less
is more on these instruments.
So, when you want to pull out
a deeper sound or when you want
to project more, it's
actually better
to let the instrument do what it
does best, as opposed to trying
to you know put your muscle
into it and pull it out kicking
and screaming kind of thing, so.
>> NICHOLAS BROWN: Wonderful
thank you for sharing those.
Kati, what do you think
of your piece being performed
on these instruments.
>> KATI AGOCS: You know
I haven't heard it yet,
because I had an eight-hour
delay getting out of Boston.
So, I just, I was hoping to be
able to hear the rehearsal today,
but I didn't have that chance,
but I'm so thrilled to be here.
And I'm going to be hearing
it fresh tonight with you.
So, I can't wait to hear it.
>> NICHOLAS BROWN: Wonderful.
Could all of you maybe share a
bit about how you started working
with Kati, or with each other?
>> RACHEL DESOER: Sure, we actually
as a quartet began a commissioning
project a couple of years ago now.
We commissioned four
female, Canadian composers,
because we just wanted to expand
the repertoire for our genre
by female composers who are
still under represented.
And so, we just looked basically
through every composer we'd ever
heard of from Canada and listened
to their works and Kati was
one of the four that really
that really jumped out to
us as just really strong
and we really just felt
connected to what she was writing.
And so, we asked her and
she graciously agreed
to write us this 17-minute work.
And since then we've
been learning the piece
and we've had some Skype sessions.
And we've had a couple
of performances
that she's been able to attend.
So, it continues to be a sort
of great collaboration of trying
to bring what she wrote to life.
>> KATI AGOCS: It's nice when your
piece has a life, it collectively.
Now, now we have a bit
of a history with it.
We've worked together in Toronto on
it, we've worked in Ottawa on it.
We've done Skype from
Boston to Canada.
And what happens is we all get
more of an investment in it.
And that's really nice, it's
nice to see the piece grow
and our collaboration grow.
And I think when I
first gave it to them,
they maybe weren't quite sure
exactly what I was giving them,
so I really thank them for having
confidence in me and faith in me
and learning about the
music, being so open to it.
>> NICHOLAS BROWN: Great.
Anyone else?
Or did that cover it?
>> CAITLIN BOYLE: Yes,
that covered it [laughter].
>> NICHOLAS BROWN: The
title of your piece is
of course "Tantric Variations."
Could you tell us a little
bit about the through process
that went behind creating the piece
and then maybe also some thoughts
of the use of variation form.
>> KATI AGOCS: Yes, so Tantric
is from the Sanskrit Tan
which means to weave out or to spin.
So, we weaved this trans of our
nature into a unified whole.
And I always have been fascinated
by variations, but I never,
this is my first time
working in variations.
And the thing about
variations is it's usually,
composers usually do
discrete variations
because it's easier to do that.
It's harder to make a long form,
a continuous form with them
because it's hard to have
enough textural contrast.
But I'm really interested
in large form.
I like my forms to be continuous,
not in separate movements.
So, what I ended up
doing was taking a very,
very simple elemental motive.
It's just like a little turn figure,
or embellishing of a single note,
kind of like, daa,
da, da, da, da, dum.
And I just use this motive
throughout the entire piece,
the entire piece is in
medication just on this one motive.
But what I do is the motive
gets increasingly melodic
and it gets spun out as
the piece progresses.
So, you hear it spun
into longer melodies
and then the variations start
to interrupt each other,
even invade each other so
the form becomes dynamic.
And ultimately it's kind of a
purification process of this motive
because it flowers into a sort
of fuller version of itself.
And what you should listen
for is there's a duet
between the two violins close
to the end where it sort
of reaches its full self.
and then at the end
it gets distilled
down to just a single note, because
we don't really need to turn anymore
by that point, it's sort of
purified down, and so the piece ends
with just single harmonics
on the violins.
So, it's kind of like a purification
process that we all go on together,
journey that we all go on.
Me as the composer, and
you as the audience,
and the quartet, obviously.
And I think if I had to sum it up,
it would be like developing
variations then,
sort of like what Brahms would
have done, but my own version
of developing variations.
>> NICHOLAS BROWN: Very cool.
Maybe for the quartet, what have the
new discoveries been with the piece
from performance to performance.
Now, I think this will be the fifth
performance overall, is that right?
Or fourth, something like that.
It's in your program.
So, like have there been
surprises from one venue
to another, or from one experience.
Or has there been feedback from Kati
that has changed the way you're
approached certain section
or variations.
>> MIN-JEONG KOH: I think
we're extremely fortunate
that Kati's alive.
Because musical notation
can be so limiting.
So, a process like this or project
like this I think it really
teaches you that I think
when we play Beethoven, or other
pieces I think we shouldn't get
so hung up on you know
little musical notations
that I think could
somehow not be in line
with what the composer had in mind.
And I think I mean because
you know people argue over it
and there's scholars and
there's all these things.
But, no one would really know.
No one really talked
to Beethoven, right.
But we're lucky and this project
is awesome because we can Skype
or we can text her and say oh,
is this bowing what you meant?
And so, it's been an amazing
experience in that sense.
Seeing the piece come
alive and for us
to like you know have
custody over it together and.
>> CAITLIN BOYLE: Yeah, I
think in the beginning for me,
like when Kati gave it to us.
It was very scary.
Like, I think partly because you
said it was a large-scale work.
So, I wasn't able to, well
it just took a while for me
to understand the form and
the different variations.
And so, as we play it more and more,
like I'm just able to hear more
and more of the different
textures and the different ways
that you developed the variations.
So, it definitely is a process.
>> SARAH NEMATALLAH: And
Kati's writing is very
technically difficult.
It's not. Well I mean you
don't, there's a lot of passages
that are quite challenging.
Sorry, maybe that's going to
expose myself as incompetent.
But, you know like I mean
some composers are, you know,
or in different pieces you know
they push the hardest more,
or more or less.
But this, I think is,
yeah challenging.
So, we had to do some you know
slow metronome practice for a while
on it before we were able
to really build it up, yeah.
>> NICHOLAS BROWN: Great.
Kati, how does your style in
this piece compare or contrast
from your other compositions,
like your orchestral
works, or your vocal works?
>> KATI AGOCS: Yeah, I had just
finished a big orchestral choral
work right before I started this
and it's called "Debrecen Passion."
And there are actually,
it was recorded
on an album of [inaudible] music.
And that's for sale in the
lobby during intermission,
if you're interested.
So, it was my Guggenheim piece.
I had a Guggenheim Fellowship which
was a tremendous gift and I've been
so immersed in it for a year or
more and so when that was over
and I had to write the quartet.
It was like starting
from scratch again.
I didn't know how it would start.
Because I was so just into
that piece and so I had
to do something completely
different.
And just start again and
I think with each work,
I'm trying to distill things
down to a more pure approach.
And, so I think this piece
does that a little bit.
Hopefully.
>> NICHOLAS BROWN: One question for
all of you is what are your thoughts
on the Canadian new music scene
and the American new music scene
and are there differences.
What have your experiences been?
>> SARAH NEMATALLAH: I wonder
what you think about that Kati,
because you have your hand in both.
>> KATI AGOCS: Yeah, so I'm
an American citizen too.
So, the United States
is a much bigger pond.
Well, you guys can tell me
what you think after I answer.
But Canada is a much smaller pond.
There's fewer composers.
There are amazing performing
artist, but fewer.
And so, when you're in this
country, it's kind of a little less,
it can be sort of cold, more
competitive and in a certain way.
Whereas Canada supposedly
has government funding.
Although that can be, like we
supposedly have a lot more funding
in Canada, but then it doesn't
always end up being true, so.
>> SARAH NEMATALLAH: It depends on
what province you're in as well,
the provinces support differently.
>> KATI AGOCS: Yeah, so one
is a little more aligned
with like the state.
Like, I'm always getting
commissioned by,
like I got commissioned by
the government of Canada
to write a fanfare for the
150th anniversary of Canada.
That would never happen here.
Like, here one is like on one's own
and one just follows one's path.
So, it's more like a
bit more state mandated
in Canada, or province mandated.
So, I'm lucky that I
get to sort of live
in these two worlds
and do work in both.
But what you guys think?
>> RACHEL DESOER: Yeah, I would
agree I mean I think it just
like everything else,
the major difference
between the countries is population.
And therefore, the
size of all that stuff.
So, I think that yeah, that's right,
what I'm always told by Americans is
that we have a lot
of funding in Canada.
And then I see a lot of people
in America commissioning using
private foundation funds.
So, it's always this thing of
like America has foundations
and Canada has government grants.
And I don't really know
if one is more supportive
than the other in the end, but yeah.
>> KATI AGOCS: It kind of evens out.
>> RACHEL DESOER: Yeah.
>> NICHOLAS BROWN: Well, just
to give the audience a bit
of background on our
commissioning programs.
We have a very interesting case
of modeling our commissions
on the public-private partnership.
So, beginning in 1925 when Mrs.
Coolidge established the concert
series here, she really
wanted an institution to take
on the administration of her vision
to make the concerts and music
over to the public and available.
But also, to have the
sense of permanence
that private foundations
often don't have.
Unless you're like the
Guggenheim or that kind of thing.
So, Mrs. Coolidge went to Congress.
She was quite the character.
Five years into voting rights
this woman went to Congress
and lobbied all kind of everyone
to get legislation enacted
to allow the government
to accept private funds
for cultural programming and
for building the concert hall.
This hadn't happened
in this way before,
so it was really a novel thing.
And since then, we've had
many other supporters.
Some of you are here and come
to our concerts all the time,
who make these commissions possible
by giving financial contributions
or helping us get to
other foundations.
And so, while we are, the Library
of Congress as the commissioner,
there's always a private foundation
or fund associated
with the commission.
So, for example, our McKim Fund
commissions violin and piano works.
It's the Library of
Congress McKim Fund.
Or, Mrs. Coolidge's foundation
is the Elizabeth Sprague Coolidge
foundation in the Library
of Congress.
So, here we are, the government's
administering all this,
but the government is not
necessarily giving the money
for the commissions.
So far this model has worked very
well for protecting the integrity
of the series and making
sure it keeps going.
I'm sure the audience
could guess why
that would be the case
in a public only model.
So, we consider ourselves
very fortunate
to have this opportunity
to commission folks.
And it's always interesting to hear
what the other models are out there.
And one of our favorite
things to do is
to co-commission with other people.
So, if there's ever any ideas about
that, feel free to let us know.
Great. So, one of the things
that I'd love to ask the quartet
about is your experience
seeing the manuscripts
that are just through there.
So, there are some really
nice treats for all of you
to see before the concert,
including a Mozart manuscript
and a Heiden manuscript, as well
as a letter written by Mendelson
in which he describes
composing the quartet that is
on the program this evening.
So, tell me a bit about your
experience seeing those.
Because I know I totally
surprised it on you last night.
>> CAITLIN BOYLE: Well, I think for
me, like sometimes I feel so far,
well I do and I don't,
but I feel so far
from music that's been written
so long ago, in one way.
And I think seeing
manuscripts like this,
like makes me feel closer
somehow to this music.
So, for me it is just incredible,
that it's just the right here.
And even yeah, I was looking
around the library today
and it's just incredible, like the
artifacts and all the exhibitions
and the building itself, so.
>> RACHEL DESOER: Yeah,
I'm always amazed
by how unintelligible
manuscripts look to me because.
>> NICHOLAS BROWN: As
well as Kati's [laughter].
>> RACHEL DESOER: Well, since
the computer age it's a lot
more intelligible.
But actually, the Gubaidulina
that we're also playing is
also not computer generated.
So, it's very hard to read.
And it just makes just
admire the amount of research
that actually goes into learning how
to read what the composer
probably meant.
And research that we
don't really do much of.
So, we kind of rely on people
who work in these libraries
and for publishers to like,
to decipher these manuscripts
and then publish them so
that we can understand.
And then the other thing I
really noticed is Mendelson,
there's a beautiful little
painting in one of the letters,
I hope you'll check it out.
And it's just so small
and detailed and gorgeous.
That you know as we know Mendelson
was so great at writing literature,
and writing music, and painting,
and you know real Renaissance man.
And so, does the beauty
of this painting is just,
struck me once again
in a negative way,
just how greedy some
people are [laughter].
At just being so talented
in so many areas.
But it's really beautiful.
>> NICHOLAS BROWN: Great.
One of the wonderful connections
between some of the items in there
and the concert is
that Mrs. Witthalll,
who of course donated the
instruments and built this room,
donated Mozart, Beethoven,
Schubert, Mendelson,
and Schoenberg manuscripts
to the library.
And she's very much one of the
core reasons why we have the
world-renowned collection of
transcripts of European composers
that we have here at the library.
And for those of you who are the
nerdy type, and that's a good thing,
that is a badge of
honor in this building.
The high-resolution scans of most of
those items by these composers are
up online on our website.
You can download them,
you can play from them
if you can decipher anything.
So, enjoy them.
You can also print them out and make
them gifs, you know; gifs and gifts
if anyone's into make gifs.
And so, I definitely encourage
you to check those resources out,
they're available at LOC.gov.
And also in your program booklet
when you get them inside you'll
see some of the highlights
from the Mendelson collections
are listed specifically.
And with some QR codes and
links for you to check out.
One of the great manuscripts that
we have is the Octet manuscript,
which is kind of, just like
every time you get near it.
and while they were rehearsing last
night I was having fun putting items
in the cases with my
colleague Bob, so.
>> KATI AGOCS: There's something so
special about the handwritten score
that we're losing now with
all the computer annotation.
And when one looks at those
scores one can see the personality
of the composer, just, one can
feel it just jumping off the page.
>> NICHOLAS BROWN:
Definitely and some of them,
the Beethoven manuscripts of course,
it's just like scratching it out
and writing on top of things in
different types of pen or pencil,
and also the paper quality
differences are kind of interesting
to see from the 18th century
and early 19th century.
Sometimes you can tell who was
working in a better situation,
or who had a wealthier patron, that
kind of thing, by the paper quality.
And then some of the like
19th century American stuff
around the Civil War is a little
dicey in terms of paper quality.
But, and what excites you all most
about the performance tonight?
>> MIN-JEONG KOH: Well, I don't know
if you've noticed but we have a bit
of a girl power theme going on.
>> NICHOLAS BROWN: It's pretty
great, we love [laughter].
>> MIN-JEONG KOH: And being here
I think, I mean it's a huge honor
and we're excited to
bring Kati along with us
and to be playing Gubaidulina here.
And like you said before, I mean
the library here is well known
for its beautiful collection
of instruments,
but it's also quite well known
because of the two leading women
philanthropists of that time.
And I think it's just a huge
privilege and an honor for us
to be a part of that
celebration here.
And she's a girl too, so.
Yeah, girls.
>> NICHOLAS BROWN: Yes, we have
an extra member of the quartet
on board, which should
be really exciting.
So, does she move when you play?
>> MIN-JEONG KOH: Yeah.
>> NICHOLAS BROWN: Oh, that's great.
>> MIN-JEONG KOH: Only when
we play female composer,
I'm just kidding [laugther].
>> NICHOLAS BROWN: That's awesome.
>> MIN-JEONG KOH: Just kidding.
>> KATI AGOCS: I'm really
honored to be on a program
with these composers, especially
Gubaidulina, whom I met in Paris
and was lovely and thank you
for performing living composers.
>> NICHOLAS BROWN: Oh, thank you
for giving us something to perform.
Yeah, you know that's one of the
big reasons why Mrs. Coolidge came
to us was because she that new
music component really kept safe
and is one of the best
things about our government.
There's new music going on on
Capitol Hill, supported by Congress
which I know most people would never
believe, but we're very thankful
for the opportunity to
be able to do this here
and to have a broader
community with composers
and with artists such as yourselves.
And I think as this point
we'll open up to Q&A.
To give you all a chance
to chat with the artists.
If you will just hold one second for
the microphone, I think Jay is going
to come around and get one.
If you just hold your hands up for
a bit and Jay will, there you go.
This is Jay.
Everyone on camera world.
Waive, Jay.
>> AUDIENCE 1: I want to
ask about the Canadian scene
and your two cultures
if there are differences
in the way music is created and you
know tastes and things like that.
Because you have the French and
English aspect of your culture.
>> SARAH NEMATALLAH: I think all
the provinces are really different.
We've been fortunate enough to be
able to travel over much of Canada,
actually from coast-to-coast.
The only place that we haven't been
able to visit yet is the north,
which I hope to go to someday, soon.
But I've just been astounded
at how different each
of the provinces are,
each of the cities.
Like real, there's
almost small cultures
within you know, each province.
So, it's a little hard to give
sort of a broad generalization
to the whole country
because of that.
And then, of course the individual
composers are all are so unique.
I mean the four that we chose they
couldn't have been more different.
Like one is into electronic
music, very heavily.
You know one is into very, very
minimalist sort of textural music.
It's been yeah, it's
been really enlightening.
I don't know.
I don't if that's a very
good answer for you but.
>> KATI AGOCS: But just,
maybe to just build upon that,
you're going to be recording
all four works, right.
Then in the next year or so there
should be a recording of those four?
>> SARAH NEMATALLAH: That's right.
>> KATI AGOCS: So, you'll be
able to hear the range there,
between at least a small subset.
But from composers from
different parts of Canada
and different aesthetic backgrounds.
>> SARAH NEMATALLAH:
Yeah, absolutely.
>> NICHOLAS BROWN: Oh, we'll go over
here, oh, Jay's got one in the back.
>> AUDIENCE 2: I'm curious to
know, you're such modern artists
and composers yourselves and to
hold such old, old objects that it's
so rare in life to in particularly
on this continent to confront
or engage with such old objects,
or pieces of art, or
houses, or buildings.
And what that must be like from your
experiences as musicians and artists
to behold something so old
in such a modern world.
>> SARAH NEMATALLAH:
Great fear [laughter].
Terror. Terror of being
sued for doing something.
I'm just kidding [laughter].
>> NICHOLAS BROWN: We
wouldn't do that to you.
>> CAITLIN BOYLE: I
think another thing
that I think the viola
has taught me is that,
I feel like it really
has its own voice.
It's like, it has its
own personality.
And it's kind of just
my job to kind of try
to release that or encourage it.
I mean, I know that these
instruments actually don't get
played continuously so often.
So, we also have to kind of,
it's our job a little bit
to warm them up, I think for you
know to play at that concert, but.
>> MIN-JEONG KOH: It's also amazing
to think that these instruments were
around when like Mozart
and Beethoven were
actually writing the music.
And they were being performed
on these instruments.
And we get to play on
them 200, or some 300,
I can't do math years later.
And like these instruments
will last even way after us.
You know and they'll be servicing
millions of other artists.
So, yeah it's incredible.
>> RACHEL DESOER: Yeah, everything
we're playing tonight was written
after these instruments were made
by quite a significant amount.
But I think this is maybe a little
corny but I felt this connection
when I first picked up
instrument and I was
like I know it's Stradivari
instrument from 1697.
And it's like that's so wild that
it doesn't really enter me like,
I don't really understand
that concept.
And then I'm playing it
and it sounds beautiful.
And I'm tuning it to my
iPhone [laughter], right?
Because I have an app
that tells me my pitch.
And I just felt this,
this is the corny part.
I felt like this connection
of humanity.
Like Stradivari made
this how many years ago.
I am playing it.
Technology is hearing
it, and yet it obviously,
its sound is current right.
So, it's like this thread
of creating beautiful music
for hundreds and hundreds of years.
>> NICHOLAS BROWN: That was
lovely, it wasn't corny [laughter].
Okay.
>> AUDIENCE 3: So, that's actually
a good segue to the question I had
about the composition and
the name of the composition.
But you alluded to Bach
variations and I'm wondering
about the Eastern music connection
as you were conceiving of the piece
and the different sort of approaches
to that vibrational
thread coming through.
>> KATI AGOCS: I'm always thinking
about Bach and I'm always inspired
by Back every day I
think about Bach.
And I think with developing
variations I was reference Brahms,
because he specifically
did developing variations.
In terms of the Eastern, I'm very
interested in religion in general
and spirituality and the common
threads between different religions.
So, I think I was intrigued by
using this notion of tantric
and bringing it into a work.
In my own interpretation of it
of course, because I don't know.
I'm not as well versed
in it as a lot of people,
but I just love something
about this idea of completeness
and looking for completeness.
Because it is something we all think
about and striving for completeness
in a musical work seemed
like a compelling thing.
So.
>> AUDIENCE 3: So, there's no
tangible connection the [inaudible]?
>> KATI AGOCS: Oh yeah, I had
written I had set a Sufi text prior.
I was commissioned to
set a test in in Farsi,
which was actually interesting
because I don't know Farsi and I had
to understand the pronunciation
and all the sounds
and work with Farsi speakers.
But I had set a text
in Farsi and I think
that influenced actually
thanks for brining that up.
I think that influenced.
Because that was like
a few months before.
So, that influenced how I
was thinking about this.
It was the vocal piece, so.
Yeah.
>> AUDIENCE 4: Thank you.
I just wanted to go
back to the question
about what you called
the new music scene.
You talked about it in terms of
funding between the US and Canada.
But I was actually
interested in it from the point
of view of the music itself.
You gave, such a beautiful
description of your piece
that we're going to hear tonight
and the variation, you know and how
that will unfold as we listen to it.
But I wondered, I'm
not a musician myself.
I wondered what is really going
on in the new music scene,
if it is a scene, musically
what you're finding interesting,
you know maybe you have
to name favorite composers
really to answer the question.
But if you'd say just a
little bit about that.
>> NICHOLAS BROWN: Yeah, I'll let
you all go first, then I will.
>> KATI AGOCS: I mean we
live in very pluralistic age.
So, what we're seeing now
especially in the last 10
or 15 years is it becoming
mainstream to bring influences
from other kinds of
music into concert music.
So, folk music, pop music
rap, whatever it may be.
Composers are synthesizing all
of these different influences.
And what would have been before a
more marginal thing is now becoming
more mainstream.
So, we're seeing more and
more different approaches.
And as far as, do you guys
want to build from that?
>> SARAH NEMATALLAH: Yeah,
I think diversity of style.
I think composers are they sound,
well I mean the sense I get is
composers sound more different
from each than maybe every before.
Yeah I don't know if
anyone else wants.
But I mean we know I mean
like one of the composers
that we commissioner
from Qubec actually.
So, she's a French
composer, named Nicole Lizee.
She was very influenced by
electronic music, dance music.
And a lot of sort of
lesser-known musical trends,
like I can't remember it
was like ghosts something.
>> KATI AGOCS: Yeah, she's
really into like the turntable.
She played with turntables
in her basement and she did
like the scratching
on the record players.
>> SARAH NEMATALLAH: Yeah,
and that's actually
an interesting trend.
>> KATI AGOCS: It's a retro analog.
>> SARAH NEMATALLAH:
Yeah, so I composers know
that they can't ignore technology
and a lot of them are sort
of you know trying to tap
into it and be inspired by it,
which is really interesting
for us actually.
Working on that piece was unusual
because we fully understood
where these sound ideas were coming
from, but we're playing as you said
on you know antiques that were
really never meant to be used
to make these kinds of sounds.
So, we really had to work
hard to come up with an idea
of how we were going to bring
that across on our instruments.
And then also, well I mean,
this is more international.
But I mean like we played a composer
a couple years ago from England
who is very inspired by rap
and really synthesized
that into his music.
So, that was like a
whole other sound.
We actually, we run a competition
at the University of Toronto
where we're in residence,
where we challenge the students
to write a string quartet,
15-minute string quartet.
And we choose one and we
premier and record it.
And yeah, all the, well the one
that we choose this year was written
by a woman who is very
inspired by her Balkan heritage.
So, it sounds a lot like folk music.
So that's kind of more
drawing from the past.
Very, very different
from Kati's, piece,
from piece from Nicole
Lizee's piece, from you know.
>> KATI AGOCS: But if you want
specific names, I mean ensembles
like this have to curate
right, they have to listen
to tons of music and choose.
So, you can look at an ensemble
like this, who they programmed.
And it will be interesting.
There will be some
consistent threat.
Or another ensemble that you like,
they play and you can see what new,
what new music are they doing.
And so, that can be a good entre.
Because I know it can
be a bit overwhelming.
Like how do you find the
composers out there that are good
and who to learn about and.
But you can trust them because
they're spent, they've devoted a lot
of time to learning about the music
and choosing what they want to play.
>> NICHOLAS BROWN: And from the
presenter's side I 'll throw
in some comments and hopefully not
get into anything too controversial.
But presenting contemporary
music is a complex thing, right?
So, we have what mainstream society
is trending on at a given moment.
We have what major
orchestras are programming,
which might be more
conservative or less conservative,
depending on what city,
what country.
I think there's a sense of global
connections between styles of music
that are person-to-person based.
So, you might have like, Kati
came to study in New York
and worked with Milton Babbitt.
And now you're based in Boston.
So, you have all these
connections out of that location.
And so it's not necessarily
that you're inviting this
Canadian style all the time,
you're creating your own
style that's informed
by all these different touchpoints.
And I think one of the things
that presenters struggle with is
that we can't represent all of the
great new music that's out there.
And if you compare any
presenter to another presenter,
you'll see that it's not
all the same composers,
there might be some overlap.
There might be certain artists,
or composers are being picked
up by certain radio stations,
and others who are not.
But I think my recommendation
and probably everyone else's
recommendation would be to listen
to as much as you can and make up
your own decisions about what you
like and what you don't like.
There are contemporary
music radio stations online.
There are concerts that you
can go to that are free,
like at the Library of Congress
where you can hear new things.
You can also you know go to any
public library in the country
and use their digital
subscription service,
like DC Public Library has freegle,
where you can actually go on
and download free MP3s every week.
Who knew that?
Completely free.
So, take advantage of that.
And, so it's not this culture
where you're just listening
to X radio station, it's based
in New York and get their view
of what's good in contemporary
music.
We have so much access to good
and bad information nowadays
that my personal suggestion
is to really go
out there and explore on your own.
And listen to what people
are recommending, of course,
like you know Alex Russ in "The New
Yorker" he has certain things to say
that a lot of people appreciate.
Or some people might
not appreciate them.
But Alex Russ isn't going to
cover all of the great things
that are going on in the music scene
whether it's in DC, or New York,
or Toronto, or anywhere else.
So, it's kind of this sense of
having your ear to the ground
and really forming your
own set of preferences.
Which I think is a
healthy way to go.
Do you all listen to the same music?
Probably not right?
>> SARAH NEMATALLAH: Some of
us listen to Silas [laughter].
>> NICHOLAS BROWN: Do any
of you avoid listening
to music in your off time?
>> SARAH NEMATALLAH: Sometimes.
>> CAITLIN BOYLE: Me, yeah.
>> SARAH NEMATALLAH: Yeah.
More and more over the
years, I've just been
like you know I just
want to hear my fridge.
>> CAITLIN BOYLE: Well, I think
it's, like when we spend like 6
or 8 hours a day listening
as our like primary job.
When you go home sometimes you do
want time just for a little break.
>> NICHOLAS BROWN: Definitely.
Any other questions?
>> AUDIENCE 5: Yeah.
Would you tell us a little bit
about Canadian music conservatories,
especially The University of Toronto
and is there a concerted effort
to keep the best musicians
in Canada,
not send them to Julliard or Curtis?
And can you tell us a
little bit about all
of your music education backgrounds?
>> SARAH NEMATALLAH: Well Min and
I, well actually three of us now.
So, Min and I were actually
students together at The University
of Toronto in our undergrad
and we sat beside each other
in orchestra and everything.
And so, and Caitlin also attended
the Royal Conservatory in Toronto
and then she went to
Europe later on.
And Rachel you studied in
the states primarily right.
We also spent some time at McGill.
And yeah I don't know what
you guys would say about.
>> RACHEL DESOER: Well,
I was going to say,
it's actually very strange being
in this room because on this side
of the room I'm a defector for
going to the United States to study.
And then on your side of the
room I'm someone who came
to your lovely country to study.
Anyway. So, yeah.
I would say that there's a concern,
just to address your questions
about trying to keep students.
There's a concern about the brain
drain for our musicians as well
as everything else that Canadians.
Because it is smaller
place with fewer schools
and less competitive,
and all that stuff.
And people end up a lot of the time
going to other countries to study.
That being said, I think we
have a few strong schools.
The University of Toronto
being one of them.
And there are a lot of people who
just love living in Canada so much
that they decided to stay and get
great educations like Min and Sarah.
So, I don't know I mean
there's definitely fewer options
and they are in the major cities,
right, Vancouver, Toronto, Montreal.
Those are kind of the only major
cities by an American standpoint.
And that's where we all end up.
>> MIN-JEONG KOH: Things are
already I think much different
for our students we
mentor and teach,
compared to how things were you know
when we were applying for school.
I don't remember there being
online applications or there things
and I think, there
was a bit of a fear,
or you know I think people always
wondered what the outside world was
like, and I think a lot of people
sort of were lured by that.
And I think it's great,
I think, I mean even back
in like you know the 1700s or
whatever I think, composers
or musicians would travel afar to
meet new teachers and to be able
to play for different people
so I think that's wonderful
and we do encourage students to
travel, among many other things.
But now with the technology
and YouTube
and all these apps and Apple Music.
I mean we can listen to and
watch whatever we please.
There's Medici TV.
There's, you know what I mean all of
these things weren't available to us
at our fingertips before.
And now, they all are
you know available.
I mean it's never the same as going
to a live performance and having
that experience in person.
But I think the students
nowadays have a huge advantage
of being wherever they
are, being able to study
with whoever they want on Skype.
A lot of teachers do that now.
You know there's Zookermen
among many others.
So, yeah, I think there are
advantages and disadvantages
for both, staying in
Toronto and going abroad.
>> NICHOLAS BROWN: If anyone
goes to visit Toronto,
the Royal Conservatory
building is just incredible.
How long about was it the
renovation or the remodel of that?
>> CAITLIN BOYLE: Yeah,
fairly recently.
>> NICHOLAS BROWN: So,
literally if you go to Toronto,
form my recommendation, top of your
list in terms of things to see.
It was really spectacular and there
were historical instruments all
over the place.
And there's this connection
between the older architecture
and the contemporary architecture.
So, I think we have time for one
last short question, which we'll do
up here and then we'll have
to let the artists go
to have a little break.
>> AUDIENCE 6: Could you talk a
little bit about the difficulty
if there is difficulty in
moving between classical,
western music to the pieces
represented in your program tonight
and contemporary music,
in adjusting your playing,
the way in which you use
your instruments going
from one to the other.
>> CAITLIN BOYLE: Well
I think one thing for me
about new music is just,
or contemporary music is
the extended techniques
that composers now ask you to do.
So, they're asking you to kind
of pull like a huge variety
of sounds out of your instrument.
So, you'll listen to the
beginning of Kati's piece.
So, that's just like a much, yeah,
it's a much different technique.
And so, I think that in one sense
the sound scape, just the variety
of sounds that we work
with really expands
and then there's also some staging.
Some staging things.
So, yeah there's a lot, there's a
big variety that we have to kind
of coordinate and know how
to do for contemporary music.
>> RACHEL DESOER: For me I
think the major difficulty is
that no matter how many hours we
practice, we will never know one
of these new pieces as well as
a Mozart or a Mendelson quartet,
simply because we haven't
been living
with that musical language
for most of our lives.
And as we were talking about earlier
with the different
styles of each composer.
I really feel like each new
piece I get is a completely
different language.
Like, I'm not only
learning the music,
I'm learning the language
it's written in.
So, it's really wonderful and
challenging, but I really feel
as though I don't know really the
piece I'm playing nearly as well
as I will in like 25 years.
And that's just the
way it is, you know.
>> NICHOLAS BROWN: Wonderful.
Well thank you all so much
for sharing your insights
and experiences and also
answering the questions.
We'll invite you all to join us in
the hall of course in a little bit.
The doors should open at
about 730 to the auditorium.
And please, please, please take
some time to check out the artifacts
that are on display in the cases.
They're really spectacular and
we are just so thrilled and giddy
to be sharing them
with you, as always.
And CDs will be available
for sale both for the quartet
and for Kati's recent
orchestral CD, that was released
by Boston Moderns Orchestra Project.
And are you going to
be signing afterwards?
Or? Yeah. Okay.
So, if you want them to sign
they'll be available afterwards.
Sarah's husband Don will be taking
care of business in there for you.
And please check out
our resources online.
We hope you enjoy the
concert this evening.
And a reminded about
tickets for the spring,
they are released January
4th at 10 a.m. Eastern time.
And you can visit our
website for all of the details
about that, LOC.gov/concerts.
And with that I think it's a wrap.
So, thank you all for
your attention [applause].
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.